- I actually, it's funny,
I'm wearing makeup today.
This is probably one of like five times
I've worn makeup working here.
Well, that's not true, I wear makeup
when I know I'm gonna be on camera.
- I'm a huge makeup addict.
I've been wearing makeup for
about five years straight now.
- I do love doing makeup.
I just hate taking it off, so
I don't wear it very often.
- I usually don't wear
makeup because I'm lazy
and I like to sleep.
- I don't think I'm a makeup addict.
My boyfriend would say differently.
He thinks that I put a lot of makeup on.
I don't think I do.
(upbeat music)
(dramatic music)
- I don't know what the
exact term would be,
but it's for eyebrows, to fill them in.
- Eyeliner?
I have it, it's in my makeup bag.
I might not use it for
the right purpose but...
- Eyeliner brush?
- Is there an actual name for it?
It's an eyeliner brush.
(upbeat music)
- Oh my gosh, wow!
I'm so impressed with myself right now.
- It is an eyeliner brush. Nice.
- Eyeliner brush? That's (beep).
No.
(ding)
- I got it.
- I know things. That's great.
- But I can see, I'm upset.
(dramatic music)
- Oh boy.
- I'm assuming powder
foundation's gonna last longest.
- I'm gonna eliminate powder foundation.
- I'm gonna go with liquid foundation.
- Liquid foundation because
I would throw that out first,
so, you know, you don't get acne.
- Lipstick. Lipstick?
- Lipstick and lip gloss
are really similar.
Process of elimination, I guess
it would be liquid foundation.
(upbeat music)
- Nice. I know my makeup.
(ding)
- Yes.
- I guess I just assumed that lipstick
is closer to your mouth,
so it would matter
if it was old more, I don't know.
It was clearly wrong.
(dramatic music)
- Okay, I see people online doing it
on the back of their hand.
- Um, I know that it's not
supposed to be on your hand
because that's a different
shade than your face.
- Neck or your arm, like one of the two.
- On your face because that's
where you're gonna put it.
- Maybe your neck?
- I think I've heard it to your chest
because it has the same tints
and thinness as your face.
(upbeat music)
- Wow. I normally do neck or arm.
- Okay, yeah.
(buzzer)
- I don't know.
- Oh, your jaw, well that's cheating
cuz it's already on your face.
- Yeah, that's not right.
- Wow, I started so strong.
(dramatic music)
- That is too many brushes
and I don't have that kind of money.
- I actually know this,
it's the Beautyblender
and I only know this
because I don't use one.
- Oh, Beautyblender.
- Let's say a sector brush
because I don't know what it is.
- It's the Beautyblender.
It helps apply the makeup across evenly.
(upbeat music)
- Beautyblender.
- It is the one. This is amazing, wow.
- Isn't that just a brush?
- Nice. I think I am a makeup addict.
- I felt like I was a
failure a second ago,
and now, I feel like I know my (beep).
(dramatic music)
- Oh, cat eye.
- Cat eye.
- A winged eyeliner.
- Fierce, that is what it's an example of,
but I'm gonna say cat eye.
(upbeat music)
- Winged eyeliner.
- Yeah, winged liner, cat eye, same thing.
- Close enough, right?
- I didn't realize that
there were differences,
I thought every time it just
went out, it was a cat eye.
(ding)
- Hey, meow.
- I never use it, I never do that, ever.
I don't have the skill to do that.
(dramatic music)
- Oh, threading.
- Threading.
I've never gotten it done,
I heard that it hurts.
I used to get my eyebrows waxed,
but now I just pluck it cuz I'm cheap.
(upbeat music)
- Threading, ha.
- I don't do it, it scares me.
- Threading.
- I know that one for a fact
because it's something I'm terrified of.
(dramatic music)
- I do know this, uh, do I?
- Primer goes first, powder goes last.
- Primer, foundation,
concealer, then powder.
- So, primer is number one,
foundation is number two,
that's at least what I do, then concealer,
and then you do powder.
- Primer, foundation, concealer, powder?
- Primer, concealer, foundation, powder?
(upbeat music)
(ding)
- I got it.
- That should tell you
something that I don't even...
Oh, God.
- Oh, I was right, nice.
I'm doing it correctly then.
- Boom, what'd I say?
(upbeat music)
- I did better on this than I thought,
and that either means I
spend way too much time
on YouTube or on BuzzFeed.
- I learned a lot.
I learned some things
I did not know existed.
- I feel like I'm like 50/50, I think.
- Some of those questions are wrong.
I'm upset. I'm real hurt by this.
- I knew more than I
thought I would, for sure.
- I feel very confident
about my makeup skills.
The quiz is wrong.